franz ich bin gerade bei de luca ich bin
schon aus meinem zimmer raus wir
scharren gleichen ausgehen noch
irgendwas frühstücken weil wir zu lange
geschlafen fürs frühstück wir werden auf
jeden fall ins bauens biologin das ist
ein unterirdischer trampolin parcours
funpark und das wird gleich auch richtig
cool also wir haben echte ziemlich
smaghi programm hier muss man sagen das
wird übrigens von visitbritain
organisiert und ich finde am echten
guten job gemacht und dann werden wir
mal sehen
so von - angekommen
bei diesem casting und heute werden wir
springen und so freuen wir sind raus
hier
ich war relativ lustig vielleicht gibt
mir dieser werte hier ein paar von
seinen aufnahmen und japan abgesehen
aber von relativ jung also ich weiß auch
nicht ob die was geworden sind
und jetzt gehen wir richtung hotel und
dann wahrscheinlich noch an den strand
und ich möchte für immer dieses
hässliche ding aufhalten besonders
angekommen im zimmer und das ist
eigentlich
deshalb gibt es hier hier in welcher
niemals schläft
und hier wird nicht schlafen und ist
ziemlich schön eingeht der benutzten
hostel ist ganz rustikal gehalten und
man hat mich ziemlich gut aus ich war
hier schon gesehen wahrscheinlich bei
der hinfahrt die kraft das hier ist
nämlich direkt im snowdonia national
park und hier ist es meine aussichten
zimmer ist ziemlich episch finde ich
fokussiere er
wir gehen jetzt an einen strand und
lufthutzen 18 grad aber nicht frieren
werde oder nicht oder wir frieren werden
also wir sind hier gerade am strand laut
übertreffen
wirklich spannend das ist der strand
bildung
kabul
tiefschlaf
schade
mal
das geld
so weit mehr wasser aufnehmen und dann
geschlachtet früh raus weil wir dann